legend has it that one day a new king
welcome
[Music]
who will use the power of the Trident to
God Atlantis back together one can
is the exact spot that volcko gave me my
first woman lesson not even close
you have to forget all the teaching of
the surface world go deeper one covering
your Atlantean instance he spent his
entire life training
learning to be the best
my parents made me what I am
I am the protector of the deep
[Music]
in this Trident resides the power of
Atlantis in the wrong hands it won't
bring destruction but in the hands of
the true heir it would unite above and
below the time has come before Atlantis
to rise again
we must stop him about he proposed me mm
by retrieving this early Elmo's not like
this one you don't the war is coming to
the surface whether you like it or not
my mother always knew you were special
you believe you'd be the one to unite
out to world
he's always had a key
now I need something more
a wall could be greater than a king
here
[Music]